i am now delighted to introduce our
spico
speaker daniel alvarenga daniel
is a salvadorian american journalist
based in washington dc
he is a writer for telemundo's english
language new show
radar 2020. he formerly worked as a
producer for aj plus
a digital channel by al jazeera
he regularly reports on politics social
movements and climate justice in central
america
and the united states he's the son of
refugees who fled the civil war in el
salvador
in the 1980s he studied linguistics at
the university of california
santa barbara for undergrad and received
a master's in corporate communications
from i.e university in madrid i cannot
tell you how special it is for me to
personally present daniel to you
for many years i did not see the stories
of my family as salvadorian refugees
of people from people from central
america
danielle's work seeks to
unapologetically
center the voices histories and
experiences from people of the isthmus
and i am personally thankful to him that
my nieces and nephew won't have to
experience the erasure that so many of
us have experienced
with that please help me welcome daniel
alvarenga
hi um thank you everyone i'm daniel
barenga here from washington dc
i'm originally from the la metropolitan
area which is home to the largest
amount of central american diaspora
outside of el salvador
and i'm in dc where it has like the
highest per capita it's the biggest
immigrant group
um and yes so
i'm a journalist like like i was
introduced by lean
um i originally before when i when i
signed on to this i was still working at
al jazeera aj plus i spent the last
three years there
so so much of this talk is going to
focus on my work there but i'm also now
with de la mundo for a new show and i'll
talk about that a little bit at the end
but um sort of i'm kind of
gonna walk y'all through um some of the
stories that i've worked on
some of the themes that i touched some
of my favorite stories
and sort of what shaped my storytelling
and
sort of my analysis on central americans
in the us um and globally
um and like eileen said you know part of
the reason i got into this was because i
was frustrated
um at the coverage you know i was a
student journalist
like 10 years ago then i couldn't get a
job in industry
and then i just started tweeting into
the void and started writing
writing and started blogging and then
sort of built a journalism career
starting 2014 um
with the migrant crisis that happened
that year that centered central
americans
um so you know before we get into it
i need to talk about who are central
americans
so who are central americans central
america
is seven countries um it is multi-ethnic
multi-racial and
it is you know it's not just
mestizo european it's it's home to a lot
of indigenous folks it's home to a lot
of
uh afro-indigenous folks um they don't
just speak spanish
i'm there you know parts speak english
on in belize and certain coasts
um creole languages and a lot of
indigenous languages
um it's it's a mega diverse region
and it it's it's hard to really
encapsulate it i think
um but you know i'll try to make
i'll try to make sort of footnotes on
the other central american countries but
um my reporting um is gonna focus mostly
on the top three right here
northern top three guatemala honduras
um and i'll get into sort of why that is
and that's sort of been the bulk of my
work as well
um those three countries so
here we have a look at the central
american population from 1980 to 2015
this is from a piece about how u.s
involvement in central america led to
the border crisis
um it's by aj plus um i helped produce
it
it is on youtube um so
basically there wasn't a whole lot of us
compared to today you know in 1980 there
was
like less than a million now there's
over three million
um in three decades and what happened in
1980 to now well
civil war um you know
um neoliberal economic policies in the
post-war period of el salvador
gang violence um a ton of u.s
intervention
um and this is a population for
um all central americans in the u.s but
it's largely made up of people from the
northern triangle
and the northern triangle
i never really i never really questioned
that term before you know when i came
into college it was already
being used i just thought it was like
sort of a formal place
um the formal way we referred to this
place um
so but what was the northern triangle
the northern triangles actually
it started off as not really meaning
much in terms of um
nobody used to say northern triangle
like in the 90s in the 80s
um but it was a commercial designation
it was a commercial designation
and it usually represents um free trade
neoliberal policies in the region
so it started in 1992 it gained
popularity with the free trade agreement
mexico
um and it's you know okay you know
you know sounds harmless if you think
you know neoliberal policies are
harmless but it sounds harmless
um you know this sort of designation but
it's sort of taken on a different life
since this commercial designation
so now the northern triangle is just
synonymous
with death violence
um here are a couple headlines i'll
translate them for those who don't speak
spanish
um spanish section of the chicago
tribune called it
um the northern triangle one of the most
violent zones in the world um el mundo
um called it the triangle of death
the invisible routes of refugees and
then you know
sky news has it if you can't read it's
too small um
the vicious northern triangle the
vicious gay war being fought
over every street and then this sort of
hopeful one from 2018
um the northern triangle is becoming
less murderous
but the implication is that the northern
triangle is murderous um
and you know it's through this lens
um that i came to know the northern
triangle i think most of us know the
northern triangle um
you know it came from like a a
commercial designation and it became
this narrative
um so
um the northern triangle um
is also the countries that are coming
here
the most um as you can see um this is
data from the pew research center you
can find it at the pew
research website um you know
look you know going into the trump
administration the last years of the
obama years
um you saw a ton of
migration from northern triangle to the
point where like it's sort of lumped in
on the northern triangle sort of lumped
in with itself here
and kind of counted as one entity right
and
it started it started out pacing it
started out pc
immigration from mexico which has
historically been you know
one of the more constant immigration
waves in the country
and um around 2014 he started to see a
shift um you know as a salvadoran i
always
constantly grew up meeting people coming
from el salvador they're coming through
la
they're gonna go to their next
destination you know la wa was so close
to the border
relatively i'm here in washington dc and
um i i don't remember a time growing up
i was born in 1989
um the tail end of the war i don't
recall a time where people
weren't coming to the us
from el salvador and that's also can be
said for guatemala and honduras as well
um if anything um the more recent um
waves are heavily favored honduras and
guatemala versus el salvador
um we'll get into some of that
um so then
this happened in 2018 the summer of 2018
i was a year into my job at al jazeera
i didn't really produce news um videos i
didn't i wasn't
i wasn't creating a whole lot for them i
was a freelancer but i was sort of
updating their twitter
and so i would go through all the
breaking news all the time and i was
constantly constantly pitching stories
about central america it's like we need
to talk about central america
and everyone thought that okay yeah
daniel you're from there it's it's a
niche for you you're passionate about it
um we listen we hear you um but there's
not a whole lot of audience
for um the elections in honduras
for what's going on in el salvador and
then this happens
um you know reports started coming out
um in 2018 mid-2018 that
200 children were separated
at the border um at the u.s mexican
border
um around 2 000 miners were separated
from their family and we're still seeing
some of this play out today you know
they're still
like they couldn't find 500
um you know of these reunifications like
500 of them are still sort of pending
and they can't find their parents
um some of these were younger than three
years old um
it captivated the country these
headlines were
everywhere um and these images were
everywhere
you know i was you know becoming a
journalist at this point and you know i
was showing all of my clips to my family
right i was you know all of my family is
i'm the only one who's not a refugee
my siblings are refugees from the civil
war my parents are refugees from the
civil war
um so i always share my stories with
them and at i think
at this point is when i started just not
sharing them as much or being a little
bit more selective
because um it was overwhelming for for
all of us
um to just be bombarded with this news
and it wasn't new to them they were
listening to it on the tv as well so
um but you know i'll never forget
um that moment in the newsroom that it
took
you know the theft of thousands of
children from central america
um for me to
sort of start giving editorial opinions
um because i was um kind of the only
expert in the newsroom at the time that
really understood intimately
central america and had a connection to
it so i started you know
taking on a lot of these stories um
and you know there was also the
propublica thing
um was also another kind of like
watershed moment around the same time
the same year
um when the children were separated at
the border and there was recording
um that was sort of like the the
evidence the proof um
and that was broke by pro republica and
we did a video with some of the audio
you know the border agent goes where are
you from the child says
and then and you and another child says
guatemala and then you hear a cacophony
of children crying
um and this also captivated the nation
and i was just kind of like whoa maybe
people are finally starting to listen
um to central americans
or you know tune into central american
politics
and issues um but one thing i've learned
in news and just living life that the
attention span
for the new cycle for anything really is
is only so big and for central americans
um the amnesia is pretty bad
so these images we all saw these images
plastered
everywhere two years ago um i know it's
not interactive but
i'm gonna give you a second to guess
what year do you think this is from
um you know
since this this is the stock image that
you see with every story so when i'm
looking a story up on reuters associated
press
i see this all the time and these are
kind of the images
um that a lot of articles will use as
stock images
for their articles but they're not from
the trump administration
um these images though i'm sure they're
still relevant to what's going on
um they're not from the trump
administration
they're actually from 2014 um
it got so bad in 2018 that the ap
had to fact check with its own photos um
they are being used to accuse the trump
government of
you know to being used as proof of
trump's policies
um when in fact they're actually you
know truth of
the obama-era obama-era policy um that
builds upon the legacy of george w bush
and reagan and clinton
um so you know i always want to impart
that um
sort of this immigration moment that we
were in wasn't just brought about by
trump it's been a bipartisan
strategy for years um
yeah and you know these images still get
used
you know they're still pretty relevant
to a lot of the news um going on and
there's not a lot of stock images
from ice facilities so i don't blame
german journalists for having to use
this
um because there's not a whole lot for
us to to
you know there's not a lot of people you
know going inside of these detentions
um all the time or you know or you get
like
these doctored pr photos often
um especially in the last year to
um in 2019 i started seeing a lot more
propaganda
style photos um but
you know it just shows that we just have
such an amnesia
um with central american
immigration and and and sort of
the us's relation to that region because
just six years ago
the 2014 central american unaccompanied
minor crisis when
70 000 uncompany miners came to the
border
they these kids you know they were they
were they were like kind of young
to like teens some of these kids they're
not kids anymore
they're this is six years ago they're in
college classes
they message me on twitter asking me
things um
they're part of you know
the population here in the us now and
we've forgotten about them
you know we've forgotten about them and
we forgot that they were we forgot this
happened in 2018
um and i would say 2014 was sort of like
my
my like journalism origin story because
i was so heated
at the fact that like um a lot of people
were like
you know how did this happen how did we
get here and knowing me
um i never remember a period
where salvadors didn't come here all the
time
and by extension other central americans
so to me it was very weird like
that we were acting in 2014 like this
was a new thing
and then again in 2018 we acted like it
was a new thing
and so i always want to i always push
you know i always push people in the
organizations that i'm a part of
um to really you know think a little
deeper
about the us's relationship with
central america it's only like two or
three countries away i know mexico is
massive
um but you know
there was another media moment there was
several media moments um
and one of them and there were several
deaths on the border
that had happened around this point but
i think what really galvanized people
was that children
were dying on the border in ice custody
you know we have different ones here
since fourth fifth sixth
there was i think up to seven children
um
there's been probably hundreds of
of adults that have died in ice custody
since the agency
um since the agency was open in 2013 you
can look at the records it's not just
trump it's not even just the obama era
though a lot of it ramped up um in these
last administrations
um so you know these children were dying
and again it was like whoa america is
starting to listen the u.s is starting
to listen
um they became symbols
um jacqueline kyle um
so so jacqueline kal this image here
is by a visual artist um brubes
and this image was
in so many protests across the country
so many people printed it out
i saw it at you know protests against
ice
these children have become a symbol um
here is zoe saldana
sharing uh felipe alonso another one of
the children who
um died of neglect at the border um and
then don cheadle's photo don cheadle the
actor the hollywood actor
his twitter photo to this day is still
jacqueline um a
indigenous maya girl who
was killed at the border or died of
neglect
however you want to say it um
but jacqueline khalid's name kind of
was like that's that that to me because
i know the region it didn't it didn't
sound like a
hispanic last name it sounded like
perhaps a mayan last name and
so so i did this story with the
international maya league about these
children
and um this is a quote from
juanita lopez of the international maya
league and
i'll read it out you hear about
immigrant children dying at the border
but you don't hear that these are
indigenous children dying at the border
um and this is from a video i did um
last october for indigenous peoples day
where um we explored
why is why are the majority of the
children dying the border um
indigenous why aren't we asking this
question the headlines buried
a lot um these are the indigenous
guatemalan children that have
um that passed away at the border and
you know it's there's one another child
that died after them
or like died during the same period but
was reported later
um it was a salvadoran girl i don't
think she was indigenous
um but you know
with these children these children
weren't just um indigenous
maya they became they belong to
different maya
nations um claudia was my imam
jacqueline was mayakechi
um felipe was two
juan was maya torti wilmer was chorti as
well
and carlos and so i never
saw um too much um
dwelling on their identity um
as indigenous peoples they were you know
called migrant children at best they
were called indigenous guatemalan
children but they were mostly just
called guatemalan migrant children
headlines
and um i felt that was a leaving
a lot out of the story
and so then i looked up what
about the indigenous identity of these
children
informed why they had to migrate
and if you look at the numbers of
inequality guatemala
the malnutritional rate is high across
the whole country it's even higher up to
70 percent
in more heavily um indigenous populated
areas
um 79 percent of the indigenous people
got them out of live in poverty 40
extreme poverty um so
what you're seeing here um is you know
indigenous guatemalans facing more
institutional neglect than
non-indigenous guatemalans
um and then you sort of start connecting
so like
they're also the ones disproportionately
dying
at the border as well as in guatemala
and they're also being um
displaced from ancestral lands um by
palm oil plantations as was the case of
jacqueline
there's also the issue of language
injustice
these are languages of officially
recognized languages of guatemala there
may be more these are just the ones that
the government recognizes
the vast majority of them are maya um
languages um one is another one i think
is shinka that are not maya
but these are the indigenous languages
of guatemala there's like 22 to 23 of
them depending on
what count you use and this was a huge
part of the story and eventually people
started
reporting on this but i remember when it
was breaking i was just kind of like
do we know where she's from do we know
if it's from an indigenous area and
for jacqueline's god story this had a
lot to do with it
um in fact um three maya languages not
just one three of my languages monkey
are some of the the most used languages
in immigration court in the top 25.
the problem is there is not enough
interpreters and so they're
probably not getting the same kind of
attention and articulating
um their migration and getting the same
kind of attention
that spanish speakers get um
and you know statistics say um that
speaking indigenous language
means that you'll likely are to be
denied medical care people who
who who speak spanish or english already
get denied medical care but there's this
another layer um with people who speak
indigenous languages that
they're not listened to and a lot of the
children who died
in custody um in ice custody
were indigenous may have spoken
indigenous language or you know
you know they were imprisoned with as
jin jacqueline's called case
father who spoke um his native language
which is
a mayan language and you know didn't
receive the same kind of attention
science papers he may not have
understood and
the language barrier that has to do with
their identity is
huge it's a huge part of their story
it's a huge part of
why they're leaving guatemala in the
first place not even to say
why they're more likely to die in nice
custody
um and then there was more deaths
there was more deaths this is the one
that really shook me this
really shook me because they were
salvadoran um
and it was a death of oscar alberto
martinez ramirez and his daughter
valeria i'm not going to show the photo
i think a lot of us remember the photo
um they were
they were trying to
get to brownsville texas i think over
the rio grande
and they drowned or rio bravo i'm not
quite sure but they drowned
in a river and their sort of
dead bodies were on display
on every network um
you know this this started such a heated
newsroom debate um on whether she would
which would
should we show it should anyone show it
um
just because cnn is doing it should we
do it
um and that photo again captivated
everyone there was a ton of
art about it but a lot of people don't
remember
who these people were and
it's you know we can assume we can make
a lot of assumptions that people
are fleeing el salvador
in this case because of violence you
know it has this image of violence
um the gang's homicide rate um often one
of the most dangerous countries in the
world
um i think people already sort of have a
narrative as to why people are leaving
el salvador
and poverty is one of them but i feel
that
um you know poverty in the case
of oscar martinez was a bigger factor
than violence
um so he worked at papa john's he made
350 a month
um between him and his partner they
couldn't really make ends meet and that
was their motivation
to migrate and
[Music]
you know
we talk a lot about the military
intervention in this country but
so much of the intervention is sort of
invisible um
and it's economic uh it's not just
soldiers it's not just
arms it's not just security um
you know what is the economy like in
sanborn that is making people
like oscar martinez flee here's just a
little snapshot
of the economy in salbor
incredibly neoliberalized post to war
um remember remember the northern
triangle started off as a
economic zone sort of and
you know this was a region that was very
much
um economically affected by war
and um made it vulnerable you know sort
of for free trade to come in and sort of
rebuild the region
and so in assad about went very extreme
with this
we had 20 post-war we had 20 years of a
right-wing
sort of oligarchy running things um and
they never really stopped running things
but you know we had 10 years of of
of leftist fm land um
so you know we had neoliberal reforms
that privatized telecommunications banks
electricity
and what this did was like it made the
cost of especially electricity
telecommunications double or triple for
um the population um you know
and the economy is dollarized um that's
something that's very understated
about el salvador has been a dollar
economy since 2001.
and so it has increasingly made the
country
economically harder to live by to live
in um so
what has made guatemala
establish
um for migrants
um so sorry i was looking at a comment
um you know
so let me see
so i think you know it's very much
um a very big narrative that gangs gangs
i'm not gonna dwell on gangs
um i feel that often when i'm asked to
talk about el salvador or i'm invited to
the table or the editorial table in the
past
was because trump says something about
ms-13 he calls him bad ombres he calls
them animals
and now we have to respond to it and we
have to we have to talk about it
um you know long story short
ms-13 was born in the usa um
and it has become sort of our prevailing
sort of
image of ourselves and
you know there's so much behind the gang
um at play that works against
people trying to make a life in central
america trying to survive in central
america
um one of those huge elephants in the
room
is u.s intervention in central america
and
you can't talk about the gang problem
with that u.s intervention central
america because
a lot of those kids were war refugees
for one
um a lot of those people came here
fleeing war
um and then came into
ronald reagan's of america with no
safety net and then got mass deported in
the 90s
um under the clinton administration um
once they went
harder on immigration and
you know the
u.s involvement central america goes
very far back here's a moment from
february 2019 where representative
ilhan omar grilled elliott abrams
on the trump's envoy to venezuela um
elliot abrams oversaw a lot of what was
going on in el salvador at the time
and so she used his history
to sort of make a case against him not
getting involved in venezuela
um and so in that hearing or she says
in that hearing you dismissed um as
communist propaganda report
about the massacre of el mossote in
which 800 civilians
were brutally murdered by u.s troops
that included children as young as two
years old
ermosote is the biggest scar of the
salvadoran civil war
my family who fled in the early 80s
doesn't really know a lot about it
um it it definitely it still
it still evokes a lot of um
and a lot of just like feelings for
salvadoran diaspora
um because we haven't really seen a
whole lot of justice
a whole village was scorch earth tactic
just disappeared
burned um children murdered
um women murdered um i went to el mosote
10 years ago and 20 years 20 or 30 years
after the massacre there's still
blood on some of the bricks that make
the
the new the new church because the
original one was broke down
um with people inside and so ilhan omar
you know you know somehow broke through
the usual u.s amnesia of central america
and
went straight um come to the jugular and
not only grilled elliott abrams
on it's on also about the ishii
indigenous maya massacre that happened
in guatemala and the country war in
nicaragua
um and
interest googling hit
a historical high um it measures it here
from 100
but 100 means just like the peak of what
that term has been searched
and that happened in february to um
that happened yeah in february um
2019. um and
it was it was a big deal it sort of um
you know
it sort of brought back into the
collective consciousness of the us you
know a rare moment that like
hey like central american refugees is
not a problem that started with the
trump administration
um here's a snapshot of some of the u.s
military involvement
uh in the region
by far not exhausted but you know for
the countries we're talking about some
of the most significant or the
salvadoran civil war where
75 000 people died 85 80 and this is
according to the
truth commission um 85
of the acts of violence committed by the
u.s backed or committed by u.s backstage
agents
that is the death squads um the salvador
military it was backed by the us
um started with actually carter and then
reagan sort of blew up these military
budgets and
made it this sort of deadly um
this deadly you know
thing that happened and guatemala's war
was
longer um just 12 years from 1919 to
what the miles was from 1966
to 1996. um
200 000 died 93 of human violations
almost all of them were committed by u.s
backseat agents
and the guatemala civil war also had the
characteristic of being a very um
very over indigenous genocide um where
they've even had trials um guatemala has
actually had as
has had trials um and sought justice
against war criminals something that
is still lagging on like 30 to 40 years
later um
and then in 2019 2009 i mean
oh sorry that's my cat um in 2009 there
was a u.s back coup
um in honduras that destabilize the
country
um it's why you see so many migrants
from
honduras to this day um and this is just
a snapshot like
we're not even talking about the other
central american countries like the
panama invasion in 1989 or 90
um nicaragua's wars um
you know sometimes i like to call the
80s just the central american wars
because
you know there was a stage in el
salvador stage guatemala a stage in
nicaragua and then honduras
was also militarizing not technically at
war but with us
um and you know the honduran military
committed massacres in sabor
killed hundreds um and they were hostile
to refugees from the other countries
and we're militarizing as well and
so i often include when i talk about
central america
um i often call it just the central
american wars um kind of like
how a lot of people talk about vietnam
and has different stages in different
countries right
um but you know central america is not
super unique
um us military um interventions latin
america
go as far back as a monroe doctrine like
a hundred years ago
um and as you can see you know from 1980
to now
these populations have just gotten
just they have just increased have
increased
um salvadorans being the largest central
american
group um in the u.s
um so
you know i focus on these three
countries but displacement of central
americans affects the whole region
here's an
article from belize um you know
the neighboring countries end up having
to absorb a lot of
um this it doesn't just affect our
countries you know belize
will have um refugee communities mexico
has
almost a hundred thousand refugees in
the suburbs refugees and asylum seekers
um there's around five hundred thousand
refugees and some seekers from the
northern triangle
um three hundred thousand are are
internally displaced in a personal
silver
the displacement doesn't happen when
they leave the country often
displacement usually happens when
it happens internally first and this is
true when my parents fled you know their
villages got too dangerous so then they
went to the capitol
and then from the capitol they went to
um the u.s
and um internal displacement is a huge
problem um in the northern triangle
specifically
um and nicaraguans also
um have sought international protection
last year um
a lot of them a lot of the migration
from nicaragua also involves costa rica
costa rica is a big country a country
that receives a big number of refugees
as well so the narrative of central
america is also
beyond central america and the us having
just this like really toxic relationship
it's also like or northern triangle in
the u.s having to talk to youtube it
also involves mexico
heavily involves mexico um and
it involves the other countries as well
um
here's something just to show just the
more invisible the more invisible
um interventions that make that
that that that people may not know about
it's not as overt you know
one is the dr capta which was a free
trade agreement similar to nafta
and it basically gave multinationals the
influence over domestic trade and in
countries like salvador
um in guatemala that are sort of
recovered were recovering
from war a lot of their infrastructure
was shaped by these policies
um there's a special case also that i
found from ensemble where the us
threatened to withhold
300 million in millennium challenge
corporation development aid um
because el salvador salvador and farmers
were
wanting to use native seeds and not
monsanto
so this was basically a paid incentive
to use monsanto seeds which um
are more expensive you have to renew
them
um they they don't they don't um
how do i say it um you can just keep
growing
from with native seeds you can just keep
growing generation of
corn after generation of corn for
example but these monsanto seeds like
you have to buy the seeds
every time you're going to plant them
you can't just grow your own from the
corn it's
this weird um it's this weird
frankenstein sort of
experiment that they're doing with the
people of the but you know i got this
from the community and solidarity from
people in sarawak that works on a ton of
environmental issues in the region
um another thing that's making central
america unlivable
climate change 3.9 million climate
refugees
in central america um and mexico
predicted in the next 30 years um
central america's dry quarter it's going
through droughts
um this is especially true in the cell
below
um which has the least amount of natural
resources because of size
um but basically the dry quarter is
where a lot of crops are you know
because of the effects of climate change
um and not just climate change but sort
of agribusiness in the region like palm
oil plantations
um and sugarcane plantations you know
displacing
um where people would just grow their
food for them to eat um
it has resulted and as well as climate
change has resulted in this like
sort of perfect storm for environmental
crises
um you know this region is also prone to
hurricanes from to earthquakes prone to
volcanoes
[Music]
el salvador has a
incredible water scarcity problem
um here is a climate activist a water
activist in cebu
who talks about how unequal unjust
um water
um scarcity is is sort of
affecting the lives of daily rural
salvadorans um you see you know the
debate over el salvador over privatizing
water they privatized everything else
because it's a
neoliberal economy so now they're like
oh how about water
and um water is already becoming
inaccessible and
some might argue is very privatized now
um if you don't have a faucet which a
lot of rules have orange don't
you're you're end up paying almost four
dollars for a glass or
for a jug of water when your daily
earning is
six dollars for example um and you know
this is the way that you know economic
policies
um and economic principles neoliberal
principles imported from the u.s
make it hard for everyday salvadorans to
live it's also
central america is also a region that is
incredibly hostile for people trying to
protect these national resources
especially true in honduras
that has been named one of the most
dangerous countries for environmental
assistance in 2017
um a year after berta castro's length
indigenous activists
was shot and killed in her home for
opposing a dam
and this photo's more recent um las
vegas
are an afro-indigenous group in honduras
um
four um of their land offenders have
gone missing
um because the honduran government wants
to put resorts there and multinationals
and the under government prefer to have
resorts there than um
let garifuna people live on their
ancestral land
um and i think i'm a little bit over
time but you know just wanted to sort of
sort of conclude with these words
by um nana teresa um
um elder with the mind league
um and i encourage you all to check out
the mind link um
but she said this the governments aren't
our governments they're the governments
of the rich the business
the big businessmen the landowners and
um that encapsulates
a lot of central america and a lot of
what's making it unlivable right now
um beyond the violence beyond the
headlines and
you know this is also coming from
perspective from an indigenous woman
who is a war refugee and
um has had to leave her ancestral lands
so
um you know
that sort of concludes um kind of what i
had to say i think
uh around the 12 40 mark i was supposed
to stop um but you know
if you want to learn more i encourage
you to follow me um
these are my instagram handles but even
more so than encouraging
to follow me i want you all to watch and
subscribe to my new show
um it is an english language
um it's new and it's
it's not your abuelas and that's where
you're going to see a lot of my
reporting in the future
um but
yeah i wanted to turn it over
to perhaps the moderator
yes thank you danielle and we we do have
a few questions so we're gonna try to
get
through as many as we can so up first we
have hector peralta
who says can you perhaps talk more about
the politics of language
within headlines i'm particularly
interested
in the potential way that northern
triangle parallels the language
of banana republics yeah
um you know the northern triangle is not
a name that we gave ourselves right so
we
already don't really have any sort of
self you know autonomy
and auto determination just we were
given these names by a businessman
who wanted to create an economic zone
and
now those economic policies result in so
much social unrest
and violence that it sort of become a
shorthand for those violent countries so
yeah i do think it is it has that um
it has that sort of connotation now um
maybe a nice way of seeing been on a
republic i i definitely agree i have
been called out on
unconsciously promoting the northern
triangle name
but like it also just you know the
country conditions
have been shaped so much um by economic
policies that like
it's it's hard to to to it's hard to
sort of
extract the northern triangle label and
this is why i want more central
americans to
you know create and write about
ourselves and and come up with new ways
of naming our region
um i don't know if that answers your
question
or was i supposed to type that no um
let us know if you have um if you had
that answered your question
but up next we have cindy centeno who
is a salvadoran american documentary
filmmaker and storyteller as well
their question is how do you ensure what
are some of the actions that you take to
ensure that you're honoring the people
and their stories when sharing their
image voice etc
or more generally how would you say you
practice
ethical storytelling through your
journalism work um
you know i think one thing is consent
um you know and and
and and having that consent be very
active and and very
thoroughly explained um you know i've i
i didn't work on this story but i i've
seen stories where people will do a
story on ms-13 and honduras
and you know the people said yeah sure
use my face it's fine
and then they weren't that they were
breached onto like oh this is going to
go on youtube this is going to be global
everyone can watch the link you know
it's not just going to be a little
broadcast in a foreign country that
people are going to see
so i think it's just informing people as
much as possible about you know
how you're going to use your voice and
for what what audiences are they
exposed to and um brainstorm some of the
issues
you know beforehand research what are
some of the issues someone could run
someone could run into so but the case
of honduras is it's like okay so if this
story goes out
and they sort of half-heartedly didn't
understand
what they agreed to um let's say you
know they send a release for
the release form in a different language
um
and it wasn't explained to them because
even if the release forms in spanish
like if i'm
interviewing folks who don't have
access to the sort of type of language
they use in contracts i need to explain
that so
it's it's sitting there and and
informing the person
that you know is gonna bring your story
alive you know you they're doing you a
favor
so you also have to make sure you're not
gonna burn that bridge and not gonna
burn them in any kind of way
so within ludos case um you know
it turns out that we had a pull a piece
because they're like faces
needed to be blurred they didn't
understand how exposed they were gonna
be
um and so then you know
we took we took a video down because of
that and and having those conversations
and
and not skimping on those is how you
kind of practice it
yeah thank you up next we have sandra
sanchez
who is thanking you for all that you do
um
towards the beginning you mentioned how
you became more particular about what
stories you shared with your family
as they became heavier they're wondering
how you ground yourself amid all of that
heaviness
yeah um community um in community
honestly
i think um the reason i do what i do is
because i
sort of created a community to sort of
cope with the
central american twitter um where i got
a lot of my following as a journalist
early journalist and um my family
also helps ground me as well they're
part of that they're part of the
they inform my storytelling um part of
the reason i like to
sort of involved in my storytelling is
kind of like hey i'm working on the
story like what do you think from your
perspective like
you know i want to tell the story about
the war but like you know
um i have these facts does it line up
with what you saw
does it or not and we have a discussion
about it and um
you know sometimes it sometimes
um those things are too heavy to get
into because you know it could be very
triggering for for folks in our
community
and even just sharing news and expecting
my community to share it i know i'm
exposing them to trauma so
you know i think mental health resources
i'm lucky that as a full-time journalist
that i have access to mental health
resources
and every news ring should because of
the vicarious trauma but on top of that
being central american
i think there is a lot of work around
trauma that we need to do
i encourage the reading of martin barrow
like i think it's called um liberation
psychology which specifically addresses
our war trauma that informs a lot of our
other traumas so
um mental health and and friends
um yeah yeah i have a follow-up question
to that
um growing up in a similar way
i very much recognize now that i grew up
in both a culture
of trauma and silence um and just
not knowing why the heaviness was in the
room or
why things were the way they were partly
because the stories weren't being told
um how how do you get to that place
to even ask the questions of your family
members what is your story
all right so um i've been very blessed
to have interviewed two holocaust
survivors in my life
and they've informed um they've informed
sort of how
you know the us doesn't have a good
framework to talk about war and trauma
often like the world war ii and the
holocaust is often
um the most i think we talk about
fascism and its effects on people and
um so i drew a lot as a young person
from
from that and in interviewing a
holocaust forever as a both a young
person
in my community but also as a journalist
um one person told me that with a lot of
holocaust survivors um their parents are
two types
and i'm not comparing the sovereign
civil war to holocaust but an attract an
atrocity right
you know some parents are completely
silenced they want to forget they want
to move on because of the trauma
and some parents never stop talking
about it
um they never want to forget so they
over share they may be
um overshare too much they may not have
access to therapy
so maybe telling family telling the
family stories is the only thing they
can and
i was clearly part of that group or i
was hearing war stories at like eight or
nine
and being like uh i had to you know my
mom telling me that she had to
um identify her brother in a mass grave
because he was in the guerrilla and he
was killed by the death squads and so
you know i was exposed to these stories
early on and i feel like
you know it's a blessing disguise
because yes it's a lot of burdens a lot
of trauma but like
you know i i was also given the tools to
be able to to tell these stories to seek
them out and to have these uncomfortable
conversations and
for my parents that had given me clarity
my parents migrated in their late 20s
um early 30s so around my age so they
were also very mentally astute as to
what was going on around them they saw
their society crumble around them so i
was very lucky that i had parents who
were
open but if you don't um i say
learn about it and once your parents
find that because this is what i also
did once
the parents saw that i was learning
about it that i was trying to understand
the reality
they also opened up even more um
so yeah that's sort of been my journey
with that
yeah i remember um i don't remember when
but i remember seeing your twitter and
you sharing
something about like oh savvy parents
will just casually throw out
war trauma and that definitely in a
really sick and funny way felt
right true to me um so speaking about
twitter and media we're going to go to
emily armendar's question um who says
uh thank you for your top-notch twitter
content
and your journalism as a central
american scholar
she can't express how much it has helped
her own research and organizing work
i'm wondering if you can talk a bit
about how the media
that sometimes tries to lend sympathy
towards those
displaced from central america often
infantilizes the
individuals being targeted by state
violence id children
how can journalism academia organizing
dissolve the idea that an
individual community is deserving of
rights
respect often retroactive human decency
and garner public support for their
agency and migration without labeling
unlaboring unwavering innocence and
passive victimhood as a means of doing
so
wow okay that's a good question um
that's something that i'm trying to
figure out myself as well
um i'm constantly
um i'm constantly tasked with having to
sort of humanize central americans in a
way
that people may people in a news
organization or people online may not be
familiar with
and um you know i think
part of that is just
seeking out central american voices um
to speak for themselves to speak for
themselves and
and and also getting central american
journalism and professionals who can
speak to it not just professionals but
also um have them in the mix too
um because it's as much as it's also
it's it's as much as it's about you know
getting the right people the voices
you're not going to get those people
unless you are part of their community
um unless you're interacting with them
um
so so partially
is is also getting more central
americans in the room and not just you
know
not just salvador it's not just mestizos
not just white central americans but
like
getting people who who know how to talk
about this community who can
who can go beyond um the passive
victimhood and the innocence
and tell fuller pictures um so
you know i think it's kind of two-prong
it's it's it's it's it's it's getting
the person to ask the right question the
journalist
and and and finding the people and and
basically you know opening pathways to
you know um black indigenous and
journalists of color
um in the newsroom you know i benefited
so much from al jazeera being a middle
eastern
focused newsroom with a lot of people um
of color
in the newsroom and it you know
they they talked about issues of war and
all that stuff often
so you know i i can't i don't know what
it's like being in an all-white
institution and doing this
um you know that's part of the reason i
went to twitter to yell about it um
i think if these institutions academia
organizing whatever
art are doing it for you then create
your own path yell into the void
find people to have this conversation
with because um it's not also a
conversation that central americans we
should just be having in the media in
public it's something that we should be
having with ourselves the people in our
community
um but yeah that's a difficult question
i don't feel like i answered it too well
but um it's something that i still
struggle with
uh i i got a message separately from
emily saying that that was a great
answer so thank you
um as a follow-up to that um about a
year or two ago we had a different
pointer
uh a fellow journalist um who uh
was american with no relational ties
to the central american region
award-winning journalists
um in their coverage of gang life
in ensemble um and you mentioned earlier
how
these are often how we're depicted right
so it's either we're victims or we're
criminals
what is responsible reporting
um specifically for journalists that are
looking
into the area from an outsider gaze
can you repeat that last sentence um
what
responsibilities do journalists have
that are reporting in the region
that are looking at it from an outsider
gaze
um you know very simple listen to
central americans right
um that's that's that's been frustrating
with me too because um
these are people in the industry that
i've had to become friends with and
learn from
um and you know these are the sort of
the gatekeepers in the industry but
um you know it's this it's this fine
line of being able to
voice your critique um voice your
critique
um but also not upsetting the
gatekeepers it sucks
it's in a lot of industries it's in
academia um
i don't honestly concern myself too much
with
those people you know all the time like
obviously i have to write to their gays
often and counter
that but like you know instead of
putting my
energy into correcting every white
person every white journal who gets
something wrong um that's energy that i
could be putting into um
the central american community mentoring
other journalists um
elevating the voices of people
who are talking about this in an
appropriate way
um you know it
you know it's it's jarring it's jarring
um it's jarring it's part of the reason
i came into this work i don't
i don't really know if i would have been
in journalism if it wasn't for 2014 and
me being just so pissed off at how
mainly white journalists were covering
like oh my god where did they come from
these migrants
why are they so violent right um and
also like you know sometimes we need to
read this stuff to keep
up to date but i think you know just
always
being relentless with the critical gaze
and
you know don't be afraid to challenge
these folks who
are gatekeepers in media and industry
don't feel free to challenge me um
you know people challenge me about the
northern triangle stuff um
yeah yeah thank you and i wish we had
time for all the questions but i'll
um one final one i'm gonna go to
jessalyn pass who also happens to be the
president of our
central americans for empowerment
student group at yale
um she asks do you have any advice for
young central americans
who want to tell stories about central
america but not exclusively on trauma
but also joy family community etc
yes write about those things create
about those things you may not think
there is an audience for those things
but there totally is um
you know you know when i think of an
account that focuses on a lot of like
central american joy i would say um
there's a account called central
american beauty that just shows um
the beautiful things of our isthmus um
the
vegetation the diversity of its people
the traditions the richness of it to
tell those stories um my only advice is
to tell them and and who cares if people
don't want it
if people don't want to hear them put
them on your instagram
put them on twitter put them on medium
um and then
people will come um you know
we don't we don't we don't really we
don't need the validation so much i
don't get
i don't get the validation from my peers
in journalism i get my validation
from what my community says about my
story if they like the story and
informed
their world view about us then that for
me is a win
um but um i struggle i want to tell more
stories about
you know the good things that happened
in central america too i think the
closest i got to it was
um salvadorans palestinian salvadorans i
i did a
10 minute history explainer about that
um it still included war obviously but
like it was a lot more about the
cultural traditions and just do it just
do it don't wait for
an opportunity thank you and thank you
danielle this has been such a joy to
have you here i wish that we had more
than an
hour um i'm sure our audience members
have lots more to ask so please follow
daniel
um could you quickly mention again your
twitter handle
or information i mean if you if you
search for me
um danielle on twitter and and twitter
and instagram i'm the first thing that
comes up but my
handle is um let me write it in the chat
let's see if that'll be helpful um my
twitter handle is
at
underscore dan alvarez
and instagram is at
salvi underscore prince um i've had that
account for a while and it's just become
a thing
it's not super professional but um it is
what it is
um yeah um and don't forget to watch and
subscribe
radar2020 if you want to see more of my
stories in the future
great thank you and um to all those
watching please
uh follow other central american
journalists and writers and scholars
we're out here um so representation
definitely matters
finally i want to give a huge thanks to
yale college alum
alfredo calvo who organized all of this
last year but unfortunately we couldn't
make it happen
as the pandemic happened but here we are
so thank you for your work and labor of
love for your peers
um and that's it thank you all and have
a wonderful rest of your day
thank you for having me